you
couple questions
you
you
two minute
right hello everyone
over the holiday weekend President Trump
delivered two defining unifying and
patriotic speeches which drew widespread
praise by those who cherish our values
honor our history and seek to advance
policies that lift up all Americans
the president outlined a vision for the
future the president outlined a vision
for stronger and safer communities
President Trump said after all what do
we want we want a strong military great
education housing low taxes law and
order he went on to say we want safety
we want equal justice we want religious
liberty we want faith and family and
living in the great communities and
happy communities and safe communities
and we want great jobs and we want to be
respected by the rest of the world not
taken advantage of by the rest of the
world you went on to say we should all
want the same thing how can it be any
different than those things this message
is now more important and more timely
than ever
radical left-wing mobs seek to tear down
our monuments in our memorials everyone
from George Washington to Abraham
Lincoln to Frederick Douglass and even
Gandhi misguided movements such as
defund the police seek to leave our
communities more vulnerable than ever
case in points this weekend alone in New
York there were 44 shootings with 11
killed in Chicago 75 people were shot
with 13 killed and tragically at least
five of these individuals were children
who were killed in cities across the
country and absolutely devastating loss
and we grieve for those families crimes
such as this is dark and it is divisive
this July 4th the president said our
movement is based on lifting all
citizens to reach their fullest
god-given potential never forget we are
one family and one nation
we will teach our children to cherish
and adore their country so they can
build its future this vision is not a
culture war as the media seeks to
falsely proclaim it's an embrace of our
American family our values our freedom
and our future and with that I'll take
questions presents so supportive of
flying the Confederate flag so I think
you're referring to a tweet this morning
is that right
well I think your mischaracterizing the
tweets the tweet was aimed at pointing
out that the FBI report of the alleged
hate crime at NASCAR concluded that the
garage door pool which had been there
since last fall was obviously not
targeted at a specific individual
because in fact it was a garage pool and
in fact it was there since last fall
long before these 43 teams arrived and
it was concluded by the FBI that this
was quote not an intentional racist act
reflects my question is why is the
president so supportive of flying the
Confederate flag the president never
said that again you're taking a sweep
completely out of context the president
said that NASCAR saw bad ratings because
they took down the Confederate flag
banned the Confederate flag does he
believe NASCAR should the whole point of
the tweet was to note the incident the
alleged hate crime that it in fact was
not a hate crime at the very end the ban
on the flag was mentioned in the broader
context of the fact that he rejects this
notion that somehow NASCAR men and women
who go to these sporting events are
racist when in fact as it turns out what
we saw with the FBI report in the
alleged incident of a hate crime it was
a complete indictment of the media's
rush to judgment once again calling this
a hate crime when the FBI completely
dismissed it let me ask you about some
of the president's comments this weekend
the president said that 99% of
coronavirus cases are totally harmless
which members of the White House to run
a virus Task Force agree with that
statement so what the president was
pointing to and I am glad you brought it
up was a factual statement one that is
rooted in science and one that was
pointing out the fact that more
in this country is very low and I have
two charts that will pull up to
illustrate that the first chart is the
case fatality rates in the United States
and as you can see the mortality rate
has gone like this the case fatality
rates and also in the second chart
you'll see hopefully they have it up
behind me but the capes rates fatality
rate in this country visa the other
European countries is much lower than
let's say France and Italy and what that
speaks to is the great work of this
administration with therapeutics and rum
death severe and dexamethasone and
that's what the president was pointing
out so if you don't die is it not
harmless the president was noting the
fact that the vast majority of Americans
who contract Crona virus will come out
on the other side of this of course he
takes us very seriously of course no one
wants to see anyone in this country
contract Ovid which is why the
administration has fought hard to make
sure that's not the case with our
historic response episode John to follow
up on Peters question what is the
president's position does he think
NASCAR made a mistake by banning the
Confederate flag so he said he hooked
him this morning about this and he said
he was not making a judgment one way or
the other the intent of the tweet was to
stand up for the men and women of NASCAR
and the fans and those who have gone and
this rush to judgment of the media to
call something a hate crime when in fact
the FBI report concluded this was not an
intentional racist act and it very much
mirrors other times when there have been
a rush to judgment let's say with the
Covington boys or with Jesse Smollett
let's drill down on the Confederate flag
does he think it was a mistake for
NASCAR to ban it
the president said he wasn't making a
judgment one way or the other you're
focusing on one word at the very bottom
of a tweet that's completely taken out
of context and neglecting the complete
rush to judgment
because they that's what he said and the
president was noting the fact that in
aggregate this notion that NASCAR men
and women who have gone and who are
being demeaned and called racist and
being accused and and some venues of
committing a hate crime and against an
individual those allegations were just
dead wrong because supporters should not
take the flag to trump rally to sequence
it
the Confederate flag control remember
Allie's all flags that are not official
campaign gear our bands yes my as it
goes as a responsibility to apologize
for an investigation into a news that he
didn't report and he never even saw it
was NASCAR that found this that reported
this an even the FBI referred to it as a
news even if they said it wasn't a
specific crime against mr. Wallace when
I was further than even suggesting the
mr. Wallace should apologize well look
the FBI as I noted concluded that this
was not a hate crime and he believes it
go a long way if Bubba came out and
acknowledged that as well this was not
noted by the Vice President intentional
one of you thinks so one of the things
that one of this is where the president
comes from and this is where the
president stands he actually hinted at
this in his life force speech to those
in the media who falsely and
consistently labeled their opponents as
a racist who condemn patriotic citizens
who offer a clear and truthful defense
of American unity we want to clear and
faithful defense of American history and
unity and when you level false charges
you not only slander me you slander the
American people he believes the American
people small act in the Bubba Wallace
case and with the Covington Catholic
boys we shouldn't be so quick to jump
onto those narratives those are just
three examples of those flew back on Air
Force One after having contact with
somebody who had tested positive for the
virus why was that allowed to happen did
she have contact with the President on
the trip back and has the president
continued yes the president is tested
constantly has tested negative and those
around him are tested as well but why
was the original question is why was she
allowed to fly back on Air Force One
with the president when it was knowing
that she had had
yeah it has to refer you to Secret
Service on that but I'll tell you this
they take the president's health very
seriously they would never put him in a
situation that would put him in harm's
way on executive orders the president
has set a pretty brisk pace on those
this year and as a candidate he had been
critical of President Obama's use of
executive orders but he seems to have
really stepped up the pace on these and
I wanted to ask you know what does he
find what is the strategy behind issuing
more than one a week so far this year
and I know he's getting ready to issue
more in the coming weeks well he will
use the powers in his executive toolkit
to further the agenda of the American
people that's just intent with these
executive orders and I would just note
that with regard to the daca decision
the Supreme Court has a suggested wide
discretion to act yes
actually with regard to the present
reference about the 99 percent being
harmless this does the president worry
at all that by downplaying the severity
of the virus that it will lead Americans
to be less careful president and
downplaying the severity of the virus
what the president's noting is that at
the height of his pandemic we were at
2,500 deaths per day we are now at a
place where on July 4th there were 254
that's a tenfold decrease in mortality
on July 5th
I'm 209 individuals down 23% from last
Sunday and the lowest Sunday since March
28th the president's made clear we
grieve when just one life is lost but he
wants to note the progress that we've
made in treating this very serious virus
when we have their peuta convalescent
flies mara sov or dexamethasone on
convalescent plasma in particular was
spearheaded by this administration on
his use he's pulled down bureaucracy and
allowed us to get to a place where we
can have this declining mortality rate
just a follow-up on the thing you were
saying that we're taking the tweet out
of context but this this is what he
tweeted he says has that Bubba Wallace
apologize to all those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and we're willing
to sacrifice everything for him only to
find out that the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused lowest ratings ever how how are
we misinterpreting that I've explained
to you this I guess the fourth attempt
but we'll try it again
in aggregate what he was pointing out is
this rush to judgment to immediately say
that there is a hate crime as happened
in this case as happened with Jesse
Smollett as happened with the Covington
Catholic boys in an aggregate those
actions made it seem like Nascar men and
women were racist individuals who were
roving around and engaging in a hate
crime the president's intent was to say
no most American people are good
hard-working people I mean we should not
have this rush to judgment knee-jerk
reaction before the facts come out the
FBI did their job and determine there
was no hate crime
just the one thing that wasn't clear in
your response and that's why I asked
about it again and it follows up on
Paula's question is why should mr.
Wallace have to apologize to that when
his whole team and all these colleagues
came around to him to show support yeah
that's the best of America is coming
around when the media alleged to hate
crime on coming around and supporting
Bubba Wallace as they should have done I
think that shows how loving NASCAR fans
are and the fellow drivers but I think
it's important that we point out the
fact that there was no hate crime the
FBI concluded that time and President
Trump was merely saying that mr. Wallace
should agree with that consensus yes
Mario that's what we're trying to ask
you is why she's Mario oh I'm not going
to answer a question on the Confederate
part why would the president not crazy
NASCAR for removing the Confederate flag
particularly given the history of that
flag assembled that it has for African
Americans and also what it represents in
terms of just the the treasonous acts in
the insurrection against the Republic
so I praise them for taking that down
even if it's a rating the president
takes great offense when Americans are
knee-jerk reaction summed up as racist
in aggregate the picture being painted
here in this instant incident I seem to
be that there was that suggestion there
when in fact what we're seeing across
the nation is this vast canceled culture
where we're going to tear down our
monuments we're going to tear down
Gandhi we're going to tear down George
Washington we're going to tear down
Lincoln and it's really quite appalling
what we've seen happen across the
country and on the president once no
part in canceled culture he wants no
part and the tearing down into facing a
mathias baldwin and abolitionist
philadelphia Civil War soldiers John
Greenleaf Whittier
vandalized an abolitionist he wants no
part in this I mean he stands against
the demonization of Americans and he
stands firmly on the side of preserving
our history yes he's not I said from the
very top of his briefing he is not given
an opinion one way or the other on that
I just spoke to him this work
yes what exactly does the president see
is positive or uniting then about the
Confederate flag why is he why did he
decide to to tweet about it the
president never used those words those
are the words of a reporter not that of
the President of the United States yes
Phil the president argued on Friday and
then again on Saturday that many of the
problems the country faces stem from
quoting streaming doctrine ation and
bias in the education system if that's
the case is he working with secretary
DeVos to address what he sees as a major
problem you know what what steps is he
taking to uncheck this and could you
give us an example yeah I have to
inquire about that about specific steps
that he's taken I'm not aware of his
conversations with secretary DeVos but I
will certainly follow up but look we've
got a real problem in this country when
you have rioters who I have listed off
some of the examples of abolitionists
there seems to be zero understanding of
history when you're defacing the statue
of Matthias Baldwin and John Whittier
and ulysses s grant there seems to be a
lack of understanding and historical
knowledge when the Armenian Genocide
memorial remembering victims of all
crimes against humanity including
slavery is vandalized other seems to be
a lack of understanding of history when
the first responders sculpture is
damaged when the Polish war hero statue
the world war one Memorial the Lincoln
Memorial the World War Two memorial and
absolutely the Roberts good Shaw and the
54th regiment Washington memorial with
that honored african-american soldiers
who fought valiantly and the Civil War
was damaged in Boston we need to have a
better historical understanding and I'll
follow up with you about that what does
the president's message to Americans who
hear those messages and say that they
simply don't want to wear our masks
the president was very clear last week
that if he were in a situation where he
wasn't tested daily and he was in close
proximity and unable to social distance
that
he would wear a mask so he has made that
clear on his rally this weekend in New
Hampshire master not only handed out but
they are recommended yes point of fact
Bubba Wallace did not make any kind of
false report and I'm wondering in
general why the president thinks that
issue has worked his time and focus
right now in the midst of a deadly
pandemic and then also you said he has
no opinion on the Confederate flag why
can't this White House unambiguously
state whether or not it supports
displays of the Confederate point I said
were a part of this question than Gandhi
yeah I said that you know he was his
tweet was not to indicate approval or
disapproval of that particular policy of
NASCAR it was an aggregate to stand
against the rush to judgment to call
something a hate crime before the facts
were out when clearly the media was
wrong about this when clearly me I never
said that
perhaps one of the reporters said that
but I certainly did not but he believes
that we should be at the truth matters
and that the truth was the FBI did a
thorough investigation on and what was
concluded that there was no hate crime
here and we should all be grateful for
that grateful that NASCAR fans came
together and a great display of American
unity around a mr. Wallace but then we
should also be equally unequivocal about
the truth of this situation here and
that most Americans are great
hard-working people cultural self
workers plan holders during the pandemic
yes he's focused on two things at once
something we're all capable of doing
look the president has made clear he's
not taking a position one way or the
other in that tweeted yes yes does the
president support the Cleveland Indians
and the football team here in Washington
considering changing their names I
haven't spoken to the President on that
came up with the list of historical
figures that the president wants honor
than his in this garden of statues that
he put out this executive order about
who came up so I don't know exactly who
came up with that list I can ask about
it but it's a pretty extraordinary list
of people I think we can all agree on
the fact
that great American heroes are people
like Harriet Tubman and Frederick
Douglass and Booker T Washington and
Martin Luther King jr. these are
incredible men and women in our history
susan b anthony and billy graham so I
think we can all pretty much lively
acknowledge that these are American
heroes yes the President signed the
payroll protection program extension
over the weekend there's 132 billion
dollars in the pot what is the president
think that that money should be used for
if it's still there after August 8th and
then in a case for specifically what
should be there to help small businesses
yeah so I don't have any updates on
phase four I've mentioned that the
payroll tax is something of great
interest to the president because it
would help low low and middle income
Americans most PPP funding they've done
an extraordinary job with that small
businesses across the country have
gotten this and we've kept people on
payroll so he's very pleased with the
progress that's been made there and the
continuing functioning of the PPP veto a
bill then yeah I don't want to set
parameters or conditions that'll be up
to the president when the bill arrives
on his desk yes thank you so much as far
as the shop wants to reopen the country
what will be the criteria to cancel the
travel bans because we know the demands
are simply for European countries where
the situation is under control and on
the other hand that is no ban on
hotspots like Russia India or Mexico for
example so what is the criteria yeah so
I don't have specific criteria to give
you I'd have to refer you to the State
Department and secretary Pompeo and his
remarks on the topic during his last
press conference is where we currently
stand but president Trump and the
administration have taken bold decisive
and frequent action to secure our
homeland and a big part of that has been
these travel restrictions and we're
working with countries around the world
that we hope to have a day where energy
international travel is open but right
now this is about putting America first
and I want to say this yes every call is
now the UK are starting to open for
touring visitors but the u.s. is too bad
how do you think their world is looking
at the United States right now I think
the world is looking at
as a leader and cope in nineteen because
the chart I showed you where you have
mortality rate in Italy and UK up here
and across Europe and you have the
United States at a low more case
mortality rate it's because of the
extraordinary work that we've done on
therapeutics on getting PPE and leading
on ventilators and having excess
ventilators that we were able to deploy
around the world and help other
countries so that's what I would have to
say ANCOVA and finally I'd in with this
you know I was asked probably twelve
questions about the Confederate flag
this president focused on action and I'm
a little dismayed that I didn't receive
one question on the deaths that we got
in this country this weekend I didn't
receive one question about New York City
shootings doubling for the third
straight week and over the last seven
days shooting skyrocket by a hundred
forty two percent not one question
I didn't received one question about
five children who were killed and I'll
leave you with this remark by a dad it
broke my heart a dad of an eight year
old lost in Atlanta this weekend
they say black lives matters you killed
a child she didn't do nothing to nobody
was his quote we need to be focused on
securing our streets making sure no
lives are lost because all black lives
matter that of David Doran and that of
his eight-year-old girl thank you